c'est pas facile et très haut
surtout quand on n'est pas si
heureusement je suis bien entouré lui
c'est mon grand père me donne les
meilleurs conseils pour faire des
formules excuse des blagues super nîmes
et surtout pour parler aux flics
elle c'est mademoiselle chiffres on va
bien lui dit que lui aussi il aimerait
bien que ce soit sa maîtresse
mais aussi le jus mégots mon prof de gym
lui il répète tout le temps qu'a sportif
intelligent évite les genres et l'utile
série copains bon pour le chant n'est
encore du boulot horizontale angélus une
sa grande passion c'est la musique la
clc ma mère la plus cool des mamans est
la plus jolie de toute ces sucettes mon
amoureuse tout qu'on parle quand 12 mai
quitter sans prévenir
comme dirait mon grand père mon travail
aux fondations de notre couple
ah oui au fait vous ai pas dit je
m'appelle les petits pions
[Musique]